[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's won the masters three time the
british opened three times
and he wins our hearts every weekend and
he's uh doing golf for cbs sports nick
faldo the
lead analyst who joins us nick how are
you
oh look at you you got uh you got some
you got some spaces i'm i'm making
i've got
okay what do you have you got your
christmas ornaments here are you a
puppeteer these are
these these are the gnomes in the most
highly after the green jacket these come
a very close
second these are the most highly prized
thing i only got started the collection
last year with this fella because they
did a christmas
which i assume we hope will be only ever
christmas
gnome ever ever so he's worth a fortune
i like how nick forgot where his uh
green jackets were yesterday when jim
nance was asking
so you said like your trophies i got one
in uh
london and uh i don't know do i have two
in london i'm like
really you don't know where your
trophies are
yeah like well i i do have one in
florida and i
i actually it's current i don't make a
big fuss but i know i can
i can walk up past it every single day
on the way to the kitchen
and have a look at it and uh it's just
and there's the
claret jug you know just lying around
next to next to the wine bottles you
know so
it's hey i just like to gently remind
myself and anybody who comes in the
front door
who i was do you get three green jackets
or just
one because technically
one okay but as i said i've fortunately
i've i've
become a little plumper over the years
and i
i said another funny the funny thing was
i thought i'd try to bring a bit of
european um style italian tailoring
so i said any chance i could have a two
button one
and but they did a three button of
course and all they did was
lengthen the lapel and it still got a
buttonhole in it so it didn't really
work and um and the actual my one i wore
this year for champions dinner was a
little
tight so i might have to put in the
footer
i think it's because i've been
exercising so um
i might have to put an order in one a
smidgen [ __ ] bigger might be nice yeah
what would you shoot on the course if
you played it today
i couldn't break 80 out there i'd shoot
40 over
i mean how mr langer shot four under
you know beats target beast plays bryson
and beats him
i mean he's a he called it 250 off the t
bryson's in at 3 15. and bernie's going
in with
three words and thinking misses a green
and he hits a funky chip and he holds
the pot
i mean he is phenomenal i mean you don't
they need to talk they need that he
needs to do a
you know mental book uh you know
psychology
because he is amazingly powerful to do
that
that is some achievement i wouldn't even
go out there
i would absolutely embarrass myself and
hate it
and uh so i'm quite happy sitting in my
little 18 town
it's a lot easier dustin that
performance this
weekend could he have done the same
thing back in april
given the normal conditions in april as
opposed to november
no no exactly they're going to have to
put a little streak to that one because
you know having soft greens
um you know those first two days there's
many holes
many whole locations where the players
would pull it especially down that sixth
hole
they would pull it it would land on the
left edge of the green and just plug and
stay there well if you hit that pull
under normal grease that would be one
big bounce you'd be in the bushes
you would at best i bet you take a five
if you get a shot like that
that's you know i talk so much about you
know him
hitting the right shot in the right
place so if you decided to hit a fader
into a certain spot
you better do it if you pull it and land
it on the wrong spot
off she goes and you're usually top side
in an absolute mess
so yeah there's no way 20 under
absolutely no way
firm once you get the greens firm it's a
whole it's a completely different
strategy
uh if you assess if bryson dechambeau
came to you and said
what do you suggest what did you see i
would say
um if it's the it's the intensity of the
preparation
as we say less is more isn't it get
organized i mean
i spent a lot of time with him on the
range i like the guy
um but there's so much going on i mean
he was
chopping and changing he's got four
shafts
six heads just for his driver one of the
grips on his irons
wasn't secure he was moving that's got
to be now i'd have a kitten if that was
me in my day everything
you wanted everything organized um so
nothing's new when you go play majors
why not bring all your old stuff you
know everybody gives you brand new
clothing and shoes and stuff and they
may not
quite fit quite right um so why mess
with that i used to say now i'm coming
with old shoes all the gloves have been
checked
you check your sweaters and everything
beginning though you know you make sure
everything fits and works and uh
um so i was trying to find a way for him
to say hey that's his style that's his
mind he wants to do all that that's fine
he's different which is great
but go and do all that preparation a
couple of weeks before so when you
arrive there there's the bag of clubs
you know maybe now he likes that party
doesn't even mess with the putter
and then just go out and quietly work on
it and take everything down you know
that's old school sure
he's unique but jack did that and tiger
did that and all the best seemed to have
done that
you know preparation you'd rather come
in quietly
and then i'm sure and dustin does that
you know i chatted with dustin a lot as
well
you know and he's looking you know he
didn't want to get involved i went down
the range he said what's going on up
there so he's smashing it and he says i
can smash it
but i've got a longer driver but i don't
i don't want to use it i got a better
dinky he caused it
inking it when he just thinks that 320
yard drive
left to right so um
you know i i like that wouldn't you call
that old school but
i think a lot of athletes especially
individual sports
like to be calm and quiet before they go
and do things
you also have players who feed off the
patrons
or gallery at other tournaments but at
the masters i don't know
if that helped dustin johnson or
mattered at all that there weren't any
patrons because he
he doesn't strike me as a hey you know
like tiger loved it certain guys embrace
it uh phil loves it i don't know if
it helped dustin that there weren't any
patrons i think quite possibly if
there's a if there's one guy
who out of the top players who's like
hey
you just say to him this is the way he
is he goes fine and gets on with it
you know it's quite an enviable quality
that he just uh can deal with things and
let him go just forget about it and
that's as i said it's probably the best
one this is what you got she's fine i'm
gonna go
i'm playing good i've got a chance to
win agreed you know inside their hearts
i can promise you it was pounding um and
breathing
as you could see i mean they're still
playing for a green jacket but
you know unfortunately not having the
patrons it doesn't have that
amazing buzz electricity and kim dan can
you just imagine
if tiger this was his 15th win and he
was walking up the 18th
to do this the most amazing thing when
his 15th major
and there was nobody there so boy did he
luck out yeah
so did we so did we luck out really
because we had the most amazing
experience last year and then obviously
this one was quite you know it was a
quiet walker which i've had every week
i've always said that's the hardest
thing to me
you know you're leading a tournament or
a major and you get
you're on the team on sunday and it's uh
on the t
column or a curve off you go and you're
like
okay two two people clap and it's like
i'm playing for major
and i know if i'm going um i i think
i think the guys that cope with it
pretty well and i i
i said hey hopefully this is just it
this this one season and
and you can say hey do you remember how
crazy it was in 2020 we had nobody out
there but we're all
we're all back to normal maybe next year
he's nick faldo cbs sports lead golf
analyst
uh have you ever been in a position that
tiger was
when what are you drinking out of your
master's cup there
it's um it's some fancy fruit juice it's
too early
[Laughter]
how many how many bottles of wine do you
have in your wine cellar
okay they're not that far away
[Laughter]
you know we say literally every day this
is not a good day
to give up
if i had a drinking golf tournament who
would win
with tequila and and whiskey lovers you
know
actually we got into more american
whiskies this year as well
good old scotch irish whiskey's in an
american whiskey so we we
we've got a fine fine year of sampling
all right have you ever been in a
situation where tiger was on 12
yesterday
um not quite like that not in that spot
like no
not when it's you know like what on
earth is going on what is happening
um but again it's not amazing in the
last year that was the
pivotal hole and so is
the golfing guards watching saying just
to remind you mate that was hey
however that was really good last year
but just remember i'm the boss
you know i you know i haven't been but
you know look
his poor guy is governed by his back i
mean i don't know how much longer he can
he must he also must have amazing mental
strength to go into each week
hoping believing that the bank will
survive but if it tightens up as it did
you could see how he's gingerly getting
out that bunker that
uh you know it affects him and and it's
and he's
and he wants to play with these
youngsters and how on earth can you do
it if you
if your back isn't anything close to as
good as it was uh
in your prime also to manage a golf
course
you know because he used to overpower
now he has to sort of
manage it and he's got the acumen you
know he's obviously very
bright when it comes to that but
sometimes your ego gets in the way
you're playing with somebody you know
they want to juice it up and hit it out
there and then he wants to crank it up
there a little bit
it almost feels like that's who he's
fighting he's fighting himself
uh you know he's got the field in these
young guys but tiger in his mind
can he manage a golf course and still
win majors
well bottom line is no because um look
there's just too many
he's competing in his day he was fending
them off one at a time you know big
ernie else
would have a run at him or you know
other guys the chris demarcos or
well bob mays would have a go but they
were coming at him one at a time you
know now there's
tens and twenties of guys youngsters
you know you know sanjay m's or people
you
don't really know the names of uh if
you're a non-golfer but
look how these guys play so how do you
get in the mix you know tiger played
pretty darn good day one because he
hasn't done a lot of gold
nothing was really that good you know he
went and played really smart
good golf and you think wow that was
really impressive the 68
anything will can he thread it around
keep doing that
but but you're right then the youngsters
off they go and you start
maybe you force it and um
it's in the golf course to get a little
bit more difficult got more difficult uh
saturday set it up quite tough um
so that's when those the kids get the
advantage they're um
you know there's too many too many of
them really right now
do you miss playing sure i mean
as an athlete um gosh i wish
uh you know i think that every athlete
stops don't they
i mean you know usain bolt says i can't
run
fast enough younger or every sport and
athlete eventually comes in sure it
hurts it actually really hurts because
you
that was my love that's you know being
like being a
goal for being a competitive golfer
believing you can go out there
and win was what it was all about and so
um you know it hurt me for a long time
she had about five years to be honest
uh that i couldn't play golf like
nick faldo could and hey now it's way on
now i mean those my wins are 30 years
ago
so um but even now it's this
our
it drives us up the wall because it
dangles the carrot and even now i'm
thinking it's 63 now
i go and some days i can hit the ball on
the range great and i'm like
texting everybody i'm gonna go and play
i should go and play and i went back the
next day and i hit it
crack and i came back and lindsay goes
what's the man i said
i hit a crap today you know i said but
i'm not playing anything
but i'm upset how about if we did a
skins game of golfers over
60 you and three others
exhibition golf you know guys so we i
was doing
as you know we've done 101 zoom calls in
this coverage i was doing there but
obviously you know my love for sebby and
what a great man he was i thought oh
this dear old sebby could you just
imagine if sevi and i
could have partnered each other with a
taking on anybody i
i threw out i said we take on rory and
bryson i mean we
i bet come out of it
and while he's annoying them coughing on
their backs
you know maybe i'd make 18 parts
and you know and i'd sneak apart the
last to beat them i don't know but did
savvy used to jiggle
change in his pocket during a back swing
he never had money
[Laughter]
but he would cough in your backswing
there was the famous cough you know but
that
actually was unfortunately was a cop he
would still be coughing at four in the
morning you know
so um but but but it would occasionally
would be it'd be poor timing as one
would say yes
oh it was great great over the weekend
uh hope you're well what are you doing
the rest of the day
rest of the day do you know i i actually
want over after this i'm actually
gonna i'm gonna go sort the garage out
like
we're moving out of this house i've
gotta go and tidy up a little bit
but then you know the golf course is
only down the road and i
and i haven't hit any balls that's how
crazy is that clubs are in the car
i've got a couple of new lines i want to
try
don't know why but i've gotta i'm gonna
go out and hit some balls this afternoon
i need some fresh air set in my tower
all week so i thought it'd be fun to
uh go and hit some balls i love it
you're not cleaning your own garage
yeah man in the world
[Laughter]
yeah that's my lady so um so
uh yeah why not well i don't know what
i'm going to do for the next two months
we've got obviously by time we hit
christmas then i said to jim and he
didn't actually
we're back on in two months time you
know cbs will be back on west coast
swing and he went
wow you're right yeah so it'll that'll
go in a flash
and um hey i wish everybody well hope
everybody's safe
stay safe christmas enjoy your still
you've got thanksgiving of course in
america and then christmas
and then we hey we'd be back out we'll
be out back out on tour hopefully all
safe and sound
thanks again always great and uh once
again we always appreciated your time at
pebble beach you got up you let us off
very early in the morning and uh
always brought great sense of humor this
year i had plans well
um we we we ran into some uh
managerial situations there
yeah something like that money involved
in it money involved in it
i'll try to rally i'll i hope to uh
cross paths with you again with the show
but thank you again nick
yeah good good okay merry christmas
merry christmas thank you that's uh the
great nick faldo